I have a special guest hi hi how are you
know the truth because Alek won't is he
helping at all yes actually yes yes yes
so he's very good at cleaning so I do
most of the yeah I know that because
he's like he's so obsessive about the
cleaning it actually gets to be a little
bit annoying to the point where I'd like
to do the cleaning and then not have to
deal with the complaining it's like
damned if you do damned if you don't
like if I don't do any cleaning then I'm
a bomb you just don't do it right no
really actually got aggravated with me
because she'd cleaned the entire kitchen
I came down from doing the show I cut a
bagel in half and I got crumbs all over
the kitchen and she was right I'm sorry
Laurie are you still doing your yoga
videos has been just the change of
routine what do you mean I can go out to
dinner like you cannot remember
restaurants do you remember you used to
be able to go out to eat do I know one
thing we saving a lot of money on maybe
tens of thousands of thousand president
Trump I have a question for you but let
me just say this which is if Jesus were
alive today he would be following Lauria
and on Easter he'd be doing okay listen
in Trump will we be back to normal once
ilaria starts doing her yoga videos
again listen okay everybody knows people
are gonna die okay
some people benches just accept it okay
as long as I don't die and you don't die
my fellow Republican contributors we
should get the country back to work and
let me ask you one last question
president Trump are you doing a great
job I would give myself
a 10 out of 10 I would say I said 10
Easter Sunday we're back folks hello
ilaria Baldwin on Instagram